bonjour philippe emmanuelli bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on le voit
l'espagne 1 n'est pas n'est pas épargné
par la propagation du virus omicron
l'espagne qui prolonge ces mesures de
restriction on l'a vu avec notre
correspondante à barcelone il y à une
nouvelle maladie qui fait son apparition
on l'a dit c'est le flux rona il y avait
eu un cas en israël est ce que vous avez
été confronté à ce genre de cas
non ce genre de cas reste le moment
documentée dans les hôpitaux mais
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
était attendu c'est à dire la halle à
l'arrivée conjointe de l'épidémie du
courant d'un virus soit en tout cas d'un
variant du coran d'un virus et de la
grippe va vous n'êtes pas
épidémiologistes mais la particularité
du variant au micro de ses pouvoirs
finalement ce se joint à d'autres vacth
et à d'autres virus
oui de toute façon on sait qu'il ya une
certaine condition d'observer des co
infection de différents pathogènes et là
c'est effectivement l'arrivée
de l'épidémie de la grippe et d'une
vague de corps d'un virus qui rend
possible cette co infection français
qu'il faut s'en inquiéter ou pas
n'ont écouté tout ça fait l'objet d'une
d'une épidémie au vigilance extrêmement
précises dans le contexte actuel et pour
le moment il est trop tôt pour dire si
cette co infection du corps d'un virus
et de la grippe va être l'occasion
effectivement deux cas particulièrement
graves ou pas pour le moment il n'y a
pas
dans la littérature en tout cas
d'éléments qui permettent de s'inquiéter
particulièrement parler de la
vaccination dans votre pays parlons
d'abord de ce traitement un spray nasal
qui pourrait limiter les contaminations
de quoi s'agit-il
alors en fait tout a démarré au canada
où effectivement une étude a été lancée
dans le cadre du corps d'un virus avec
une méthode qui est ancienne et qui est
connue qui est l'application à la fois
d'un colorant le bleu de méthylène dans
le lait dans dans le nez et
l'application de lumière avec une
longueur d'onde bien particulière qui
entraîne une réaction chimique qui
produit une sorte de super désinfectants
et cette méthode avait donné des
résultats particulièrement intéressant
dans les maladies nosocomiales et avait
été appliqué dans les services
chirurgicaux notamment pour limiter la
diffusion de ces infections est bien
dans les canadiens
effectivement
essayé cette méthode encore d'un virus
et les espagnols ont suivi les canadiens
est aujourd'hui en navarre une étude a
été lancée pour voir si cette méthode
serait susceptible effectivement de
limiter le portage du coronavirus par
les patients symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques
donc c'est ça on n'a pas encore la
certitude que sa puce nos fronts
bas on pense quand même d'après les
d'après l'expérience qu'on a dans cette
méthode que cette méthode est efficace
alors là de toute façon
c'est une petite étude qui est lancée en
navarre sur environ une centaine de
patients on aura des résultats
pense assez rapidement et il ne faut pas
voir en fait cette méthode comme un
traitement de masse du coronavirus mais
bien un outil supplémentaire pour
limiter la diffusion des patients
effectivement kiki qui sont contaminés
par un virus et notamment peut-être en
milieu hospitalier et en milieu
professionnel quand et si vous dites que
c'est un instrument supplémentaire
évidemment le principal reste le vaccin
en espagne également
qu'une réaction l italique et qui impose
la vaccination obligatoire haut en plus
de cinquante ans est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure selon vous
écouter on sait maintenant de façon très
claire que effectivement la la la
mortalité dit au corona virus touche
effectivement la population plus tôt en
deuxième partie de vie donc plus tôt
après 50 ans et on sait également que la
vaccination est efficace sur les cas
graves donc on peut dire que c'est une
mesure de bon sens puisque c'est
véritablement le ciblage efficace de la
vaccination sur la population cible
touchée par les complications graves du
coronavirus les mêmes débats en espagne
qu'actuellement en france justement sur
cette vaccination potentiellement
obligatoire en tout cas sur l'imposition
d'un pass vaccinale
non il n'y a pas de débat parce qu'ici
les libertés publiques ont quand même
été
beaucoup plus respectées je vous
rappelle qu'à qu'à madrid aujourd'hui on
rentre dans les restaurants dans les
musées sans pass sanitaires il n'est pas
question ici non plus de passes
vaccinale donc la vaccination je dirais
n'a pas été aussi
politisés et qu'en france
les la vaccination est resté sur une
base essentiellement de responsabilité
individuelle et donc il n'y a pas la
même crispation politique
et j'ai chez le
l'espagnol de la rue qu'on peut observer
en france vous n'avez pas à vous en tant
que médecin cette alerte aussi de
saturation dans les hôpitaux en espagne
écouter aujourd'hui on est alors à part
la catalogne et c'est paradoxal parce
que la catalogne et la communauté
autonome qui a pris le plus de mesures
s'ils veulent élire de contraintes
vis-à-vis de sa population et c'est
aujourd'hui la communauté autonome qui
effectivement annonce le degré de
saturation le plus important dans ces
hôpitaux donc c'est assez curieux et
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut retrouver
également niveau national puisque le
taux d'incidence en espagne du variant
micron est légèrement inférieur à celui
de la france et pourtant ici il n'ya pas
de 2,2 passes annie terre ou en tout cas
le pass sanitaire n'a pas la même n'a
pas les mêmes implications en termes de
restriction des libertés qu'en france
donc tout ça est très curieux et
évidemment
il ya encore des inconnues dans la
compréhension de cette épidémie merci
beaucoup philippe emmanuelli et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin en
direct sur arte france